for many Germans winter is a time for
Christmas markets and in that sense PNA
is no exception but in another sense
it's Unique because this town has just
elected as its mayor Tim lochner a man
with open links to the farri right party
alternative for Germany many people here
aren't sure what to make of it I think
it's okay that finally someone else is
in the job that they might have a
different perspective from the main
parties maybe things will change here
soon I was really sad that this happened
let's see how things turn out Tim
lochner will take office here in the
Town Hall in February representing a
moment of Triumph for him personally but
also for the IFD this is their first
mayoral election victory in this country
it's also a demonstration of their
strength particularly here in the old
East
Germany one analyst says it's profiting
from the mainstream Pary errors the best
label today for the afd would be the
anti- green or the anti- voke party in
Germany because uh green politics Will
are no longer appreciated that much by a
big percentage of the German population
and being voke is not very attractive
for most Germans either on average the
party is polling around 30% across what
was the old East Germany but in three
states where important elections are due
in September M it's
leading the way out of the crisis is to
return to reason stop Mass Migration by
closing the borders and end migration
magnets such as Citizens benefits basic
Child Protection passport fraud and
residency for everyone who comes here
the mainstream parties have always ruled
out working with the alternative for
Germany on any level but that was when
it was struggling to win votes now it's
harder to ignore these elections in East
Germany a really um will be a really
devastating moment I think for Germany
because we will see that there will be
governments which can only be built by
an all party Coalition against the Rd on
the surface life in Eastern Germany is
calm but it's clear the tide of
far-right populism is rising
here make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer